[Music]
in the 2021 live-action mortal kombat
movie there are two main factions
fighting against one another
on one side are a ragtag group of
warriors brought together by lord raiden
to train in order to protect earth realm
from being overtaken by the forces of
outworld
on the other side is a sinister
collection of fighters assembled by the
sorcerer's shang tsung whose goal is to
eliminate earth realm's defenders
among shang tsung's hench people is the
winged hunter and atara
all in all natara has a very small role
in this version of the mortal kombat
story
while fans of the character are no doubt
thrilled to see her included she doesn't
serve much purpose in the action of the
film other than to be introduced to kung
lao's half-buzz song
she may not be the most consequential
character in the world of the game
series but she does have much more
backstory than the movie chose to
include
from her mysterious origins to her
distinct motivations natara is a unique
character in the annals of mortal kombat
history
here's what only those who have a deep
knowledge of mortal kombat lore know
about natara
natara's bat-like wings and ability to
fly sets her apart from the rest of the
characters introduced in the mortal
kombat film
the movie doesn't dive deep into this
but natara is a member of a vampire
species from the vampire realm
she has the distinction of being one of
the only representatives of her species
in the mortal kombat canon
the character debuted in the 2002 game
mortal kombat deadly alliance a revival
of swords for the franchise that
introduced new mechanics and characters
natara and her vampiric kin are
described as traveling among the many
realms looking for other beings to feast
on
similar to other vampiric legends the
vampires of mortal kombats are unable to
withstand the rays of the sun of
earthrealm and are only able to feed on
humans at night
hey do you know if any of this stuff is
organic
just asking geez at some point before
the action of deadly alliance natara's
realm was subsumed into outworld by its
emperor xiaokong
her motivation throughout the action of
the game is to secure a magical orb that
will enable her to free her realm from
outworld's control
during the tara's short stint in the
2021 mortal kombat film she mostly acts
as one of shang tsung's lackeys
similar to cabal and molina however
while working with the baddies isn't out
of character for her
in the world of the video games the only
person natara has allegiance to is
herself and her people
while many of the characters in the
mortal kombat canon either fall on the
side of good or evil natara is
distinctly neutral
when she was introduced in deadly
alliance her motivations were solely to
destroy the magical orb that is keeping
her realm tethered to outworld
she uses deception and manipulation to
get other characters to help her with
this task
deadly alliance even reveals that she
helped facilitate the execution of
outworld emperor shao khan
but only because it happened to help
advance her personal agenda
as the character gets little screen time
during the film it's hard to say
exactly what her motivations for teaming
up with shang tsung are but if she's
anything like her video game counterpart
she was likely much less loyal to him
than it appears
like many other fighting game franchises
mortal kombat is known for having
characters come back from multiple
repeat appearances throughout the series
despite the fact that she's one of the
more unique fighters though natara is
also one of the more underutilized
characters in the franchise
the only three games to feature her as a
playable character are mortal kombat
deadly alliance
mortal kombat armageddon and the gameboy
advance entry mortal kombat tournament
edition
she has been referenced and made cameo
appearances in other games though
i stepped out with natara before you
you clearly have a type aaron natara's
elusive nature in the game series makes
it even more of a thrill that she was
included in the mortal kombat film
even if it was a brief appearance check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you